لمعلومه جديده ينضم الينا ايضا من الخرطوم
بحري احمد فضل الصحفي بمكتب الجزيره
ونحاول ان نصرت ايضا الاوضاع الميدانيه
معك
نعم عاود السلاح الجو السوداني طلعاته
اليوم صباح اليوم قبل اقل من ساعه
شهدت اجواء الخصوم للسلاح الجوف يبدو
مراقبه او الاستهداف ثم طلعه اخرى كانت
لقصف اهداف على الارض لكن تبدو بعيده نوعا
ما عن ضاحيه في انحاء كافوري الى الشرق
بين المنطقه الصناعيه وشرق ايضا
المضادات الطيران التابعه ايضا رده على
طلعات
السلاح الجو بعد ذلك حتى الان تبدو
الاوضاع هادئه ولا جديده يصبر والطلعات
التي اعتادت عليها هذه المنطقه قبل اكثر
من 8 ايام وهي طلعت بدات منذ امسكي بشكل
مكثف في دائره الاداره الموس حيث شملت
الفايا شمالا وحتى
اقصى الجنوب الغربي بهذا التحرير
عن الاهداف التي يتحدث الجيش عن قصفها
لقوات الدعم السريع شرق النيل هل هي واضحه
يعني هل هي مواقع جديده بسبب التنقل لقوات
الدعم السريع ام انها مقرات سابقه تم
التعرف عليها الان هل هناك معلومات واضحه
بهذا الاطار
اكبر المشاكل التي الخرطوم البحري هي
مشكله مياه الشرب
حيث تضرط محطه مياه
لاقصى الجنوب المدينه حيث تواجد الكثيف
للقوات العسكريه في الوطنيه الجيش او
الدعم السريع لم تتمكن اقوى اصطيانه حتى
الان من صيانه المحطه لذلك
الاحياء في المدينه من انقطاع
تامر
صحيحه لا تقدر لا تستطيع ان فيه المدينه
لاخرج الراء العمليات العسكريه وجزاء
القصف الاسواق الى حد كبير لم تعد اليها
الحركه
نشاطها محدوده للغايه حركه المواصلات ايضا
محدوده يبدو ان الناس الى حد على الطلوع
والخروج شكرا جزيلا لك احمد فضل صحفي مكتب
جزيره كان معنا من الخرطوم بحري